a la actualidad ahora hablemos en la
viruela del mono mar que están diciendo
las autoridades de salud bueno vamos a
revisar que esta enfermedad no es nueva
aunque sí es extraño que haya aparecido
en estos países en los que realmente se
está reportando por eso hay tanta alarma
el primer caso se reportó en reinounido
el 7 de mayo ahora ya hay 9 casos
confirmados y varios que se están
investigando también en españa también
en portugal suecia confirmó hoy su
primer caso también eeuu ayer hizo lo
propio y también pues como decíamos
están investigando tanto en eeuu como en
canadá una decena de casos sospechosos
decíamos que era una enfermedad
relativamente habitual en algunos países
de áfrica como por ejemplo república
democrática del congo o nigeria reino
unido eeuu habían reportado algunos
brotes en la década de los 2000 pero es
que normalmente estos brotes tenían
relación con viajes con historial de
viaje a estos países y ahora mismo pues
es algo que no sucede en todos los casos
en esta ocasión y por eso pues estaba
viendo esta alarma ya hablamos entonces
de qué es la enfermedad y le pregunto
mar los síntomas que presenta esta
enfermedad de llamada el mono claro
empezamos a de hecho por ahí como su
nombre indica es un virus que se parece
mucho al de la viruela que se radicó la
enfermedad que afectaba tanto a los
hermanos que se radicó en 1980 estos
síntomas son similares aunque mucho más
leves desde la exposición hasta la
aparición de los síntomas pueden llegar
a pasar unos a 15 días aunque eso es
flexible y puede ser un poquito más este
periodo de incubación en el que no
además de este virus no es transmisible
normalmente hasta que aparecen los
síntomas luego aparece la fiebre dolores
musculares la inflamación de los
ganglios linfáticos que distingue esta
viruela de la otra no y luego después de
13 días empiezan a aparecer las típicas
conocidas lesiones en la piel que
también eran características de la
viruela que luego pues se van apoyando
se van haciendo costra hasta que se caen
y pues se termina el contagio pueden
estar entre 24 semanas con la enfermedad
lo bueno es que la tasa de letalidad
oscila entre el 1 y el 10 por ciento es
decir que no es una enfermedad como tan
el de tal en este caso también depende
de la cepa del virus que sea por suerte
parece que la de reino unido al menos es
de la tasa la cepa que tiene la
letalidad
y también importante decir que se
transmite desde reservorios de animales
que contrario que su nombre indica
normalmente no son los monos sino
animales roedores que pasan a los
humanos y luego entre humanos la tasa de
transmisión es baja por secreciones de
las heridas líquidos como la saliva
gotículas superficies infectadas este
tipo de contacto bastante cercano que
requiere para transmitirse marc le
pregunto si es la primera vez que algo
así ocurre o digamos es la primera vez
que se detecte esta biblia del mono tan
famoso por ahora no la primera vez que
se detectó en humanos fue en 1970 y
luego estos brotes han sido
relativamente habituales como decíamos
unos centenares de casos anuales en
varios países africanos sin embargo
desde entonces también se han
multiplicado los casos encontraron más
casos en 2016 que en los 40 años
anteriores y es por eso también que el
centro de control y prevención de
enfermedades del continente africano hoy
se pronunciaba al respecto dueños y mac
box y el barón men se lanzará hoy cuando
se encuentra viruela del mono en
ambientes lejanos de zonas boscosas por
supuesto la salud pública se preocupa y
aparecen muchas preguntas que deberán
ser respondidas
en áfrica
en áfrica hemos contenido muchos brotes
a lo largo de la pandemia tenemos mucha
experiencia en eliminar estos brotes en
el continente
es una experiencia de la que hablaban
estos líderes de salud africanos que
normalmente no se tiene en cuenta con
estos temas y que pues vale la pena
saber porque lo más importante por ahora
es localizar el origen de esta
enfermedad para contenerla porque además
no hay una vacuna específica contra la
viruela del mono claro marc y le
pregunto por qué se han multiplicado
entonces estos estos brotes de la
viruela pues hay varias teorías no para
empezar la vacuna de la viruela que se
inyectó de forma tan masiva para
erradicar la enfermedad como hemos
contado aquí en esta misma sección
algunas veces pues ofrece cierta
protección también contra esta
enfermedad
como familiar no tiene hasta un 85% de
protección protege también contra casos
graves entonces ahora cada vez hay más
población que no tiene esta vacuna
porque como se radicó en 1980 pues se
descartó de las cartillas de vacunación
habituales pero es que y otra alarma a
la que deberíamos estar pendientes y es
este contacto estrecho entre humanos y
entre animales que favorece que haya
cada vez más brotes esto se da también
lo hemos dicho varias veces por una
mayor deforestación por ejemplo no por
la minería ilegal que es también sucede
en muchísimos de estos países de áfrica
central es una alarma a la que
deberíamos estar pendientes porque como
hemos dicho también desde que apareció
el commit 19 cada vez puede ser más
probable que aparezcan estas
enfermedades que salta el pecho como el
mismo cobain 19 desde los animales hasta
los humanos sin embargo también para
concluir es importante decir que aunque
existe esta alarma y debemos estar
pendientes todas las voces expertas por
ahora de todos los países afectados
dicen que no se cree que haya ningún
riesgo de pandemia real hasta hasta
ahora pero igualmente pues seguiremos
pendientes claro estar pendientes
evidentemente hacer un seguimiento ese
caso pero no generar alarma lo que vamos
a hacer aquí es simplemente hablar dar
información para tomar precauciones mar
como siempre muchísimas gracias por toda
la información de salud mañana nos vemos